you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a round
three game from the second annual gash
remov Memorial 2015 this is a tournament
held in honor of voo Gaga shamov an
exceptional player who represented
Azerbaijan very well he at his peak
rating was ranked number six in the
world and he was really the player who
revived and in top-level play the modern
Benoni defense those of you interested
in that specific opening or more
generally speaking those of you
interested in sharp tactical dynamic
play having a look at games played by
vogue are out of the modern Benoni is
likely time well-spent in this game here
that we're gonna have a look at we have
the world's top two players going at it
on the white end world number two
Fabiano Caruana paired up against Magnus
Carlsen let's have a look Caruana
opening with d4 Carlsen replying with
the Dutch white ops for a king side
fianchetto meanwhile black sets up a
stone wall structure having a grip over
e for strong grip over e4 the drawback
is that e5 is weakened castles Bishop d6
keeping a watchful eye over that weak
point
b3 queen e7 not just some quick
developing natural move like castles
Queen e7 is doing what preventing white
from exchanging his bad Bishop for a
good Bishop both sides get their Queen
Bishop working and now Knight to d2 if
the knight is playing to c3 this is
masking the bishops view of e5 Knight c3
is on board black already has in mind a
developing move with tempo White's
having to react Knight d2 stays out of
the way of the bishop and taking it one
step further this Queen Knight may very
well want to follow in the king knight's
footsteps pivoting on f3 to reinforce a
5 once more black castles rook c1
this is likely to be an open or half
open file so quite logical with this
tension here between C and D pons a5
looking for the a4 pawn break activating
the rook this how this by the way is a
move we wouldn't see if the Queen Knight
had been played to the C 3 square knight
on c3 is there to conveniently defend
against an a4 break Oh III is the follow
up this is a nice square for the Queen
this is the I believe the main idea
behind e3 the Queen can develop by way
of c2 but when you question the
stability of the Queen on the C 2 square
it's probably not so safe for one it
might run into some tempo with Knight B
4 into when r4 when or if the C file
does open up I'm not sure so sure how
well the Queen acts as a leader of this
little battery on the C file III it is
Knight a 6 96 97 that's the other move
97 the bishops I'm protected there might
be this idea present for the white side
taking advantage of this fact bishop
being unprotected Knight a 6 and this
Bishop stays defended and block looks
for this nice forward move landing into
the white position at first glance well
if the knight goes there right away you
might think he just gets kicked but one
of the ideas black has is to play a 4
have the eight pawns essentially
exchanged and if you can envision this
position right here without the a pawns
on board this will act as a nice home
for a night like b1 some curious moves
going on here Knight going to the side
tonight going here first and then
dropping back well he's looking to jump
into c3a 4 where he can now exert some
pressure on the black Queen side that
goes for a minor piece in balance
capturing the knight pivoting in the
center that strong post e4 and now after
Queen to e - we have a big thing
here Karlsson going now for excuse me
he's going for a for this is a committal
move there's a couple of things that I'd
like to reference right now black at
this point is playing without their dark
square bishop and they are considering
well clearly they're considering they
were considering this move a form if
you're playing without your dark square
bishop and to make matters to emphasize
this fact a little bit more if you're
playing without a dark square bishop and
your opponent still has a dark square
bishop the exact case right here if
you're considering moving one of your
pawns that's currently positioned on a
dark square you might need to be very
very careful your dark squares could
turn out to be that much more weakened
and quite possibly taken advantage of
after there's a four move well about 20
min nearly twenty minutes was spent in
this a formal why exactly well this is
the follow-up that needs to be
considered there's some serious this is
now blacks now going to find themselves
in a pin if white decides on Bishop a3
what are you going to do put your knight
in the pin I don't know about that
you're gonna go here and now your queen
is tethered to the defense of this
Knight it's a bit uncomfortable the best
reply would be c5 having in the pond
being a pin but now there's these moves
that need to be calculated capturing on
d5 what about the knight being kicked he
has to go here what about a capture
white is now up upon I recognize these
are double isolated pawns a bit weak
after Knight c7 we could have knight c6
developing hitting the bishop defending
a for this pawn still lives for a little
bit Bishop can drop back the knight can
be hit this is a very lengthy
continuation quite forcing on White's
part a white seems to be the one who is
dictating play and still has this pawn
plus and the bishop pair this f3 move
when I was looking into to this game
here preparing to do a video such as
this the move suggested here at this
stage is f4
it was one that kind of made me cringe a
little bit because it weakens the G
Foursquare I thought whoa this night is
not too far off from occupying that
square do you really want to do this
well this Queen keep in mind if you're
the knight is trying to jump in here
real quick hang on
Queen c6 and she is super active and not
long off black can be reminded that this
bishop is in fact in the game if b6 is
no longer on board
here comes c5 and this this can get
broken down very very quickly
anyhow my main point here is to be very
careful black is - a dark square Bishop
white has a dark square bishop and black
is moving upon off of a dark square
Bishop a3 would have been the move to
try to maintain a slight advantage for
white however white spending quite some
time himself about 24 minutes ops for
Knight to c3 and this is where things
shift slightly it's roughly it's it's
about an equal position with this move
here Knight c3 and with this move we now
have a pretty forcing line some well
several exchanges happen and we zip to
move 25 pretty quick here there's a lot
of pressure being placed against b3 not
so many options with these next dozen
moves Knight takes Knight pawn takes
Knight some thought was spent on this
one here what about three minutes was
spent on this capture why not this
capture well for one this is some idea
that might be present the e6 pawn in
other words is a bit accessible a bit
more the point of vulnerable maybe even
Bishop to h3 and black is having to
devote a piece to defending that point
so it's the deep on that recaptures one
other reason to maybe go with the D pawn
recapturing is because if you're going
with this now this pawn can make it
capture at some stage and this rook is
brought to life somewhat so it is the
deep on that recaptures on e4 white
needs to defend
three black piles up on B three bishops
III the Queen's are off the rook is
going to get that pawn back black lands
a fork picks up the dark square Bishop
light gets the light square Bishop in
exchange and this is where we stand that
a lot of smoke has cleared here we're in
an ending
Queens are off board both rook both sets
of rooks a minor piece each this is the
main imbalance here well I don't even
know if I could say that's the main in
bet that's probably the main imbalance
here to focus on the night versus Bishop
but this is also a very weird structure
not so common a structure right here so
these are the things that factor and
these are the things that capture my
attention when I look at this position
and I'm trying to evaluate I'm trying to
assess this position I'm trying to see
who's who has the superior minor piece
whose minor piece is better off who
would I rather be in this position this
rook is very active this Knight has the
potential to land a fork our excuse me a
check maybe a fork at some point who
knows so it's still quite difficult to
assess at this point it is the computer
will rattle off several different
options here for the white side and it's
about all equal the move played as a
follow up here is rook to e7 which is
quite a fine move just putting pressure
on this pun and the end result of this
these next couple of moves black has to
do what black has to defend a six he
does just that and black is now having
to do what recapture and in Kentucky is
now slightly inconvenienced right he was
on an open file he's having to now
recapture and he's pulled to this closed
file it'll get back to being active this
next move is a very important one I
think at least the move played was rook
to a1 but another move to have given
strong consideration to
was the move f3 and I really would have
been curious to know how black would
have replied to this f3 is looking to
exchange the one pond to to exchange off
blacks efore ponds so that this bishop
can finally see a little bit more of the
world see the Queen side of the board
I'm not sure what blacks reply would be
at this point if the rook is playing to
the a file or B file let's just say here
going to a dark square it's just staying
clear of the light square bishop we
could have takes and what are we doing
now is black if you take like this
there's Bishop h3 this is a bit
inconvenient to black how are you
defending ecigs you have to come over
here that's completely passive are you
taking with the knight if you're taking
with the knight well there's no way
white can be worse off it's probably
going to still turn out to be a draw
this pawn is picked up and the rook
would be defending everything this is
probably some draw here with rook b2 and
should you really sideline your King
like that there's probably just some
little back-and-forth here in fact after
King to h3 rookie two rooks here
c5 maybe this is a little bit awkward
the kind of tough spot if the rook moves
you're dropping this if the King moves
you're dropping this probably best at
that point if f3 rook here takes takes
takes takes rook f4 probably best at
this point would be some type of a
repetition I don't think either side
could try for anything more the f3 break
was not played at this point here
instead white played within the
structure kept the structure as is rook
a one rope d8 Bishop f1 c5 this is
fixing the pawn on a light square also
it's getting upon off of the same rank
this might be another way to view it
it's there's no longer two black pawns
on the sixth rank if they're both on the
sixth rank there might be a variation
where the rook is able to take one pond
and be now very quick to threaten to
take another they're a bit you know they
can't be captured so quickly if if some
variation like that was to occur I
believe the main point however is to
make sure this pond does not move
fix the pond on the light square if he's
not able to move this Bishop isn't able
to become so activated getting to see
for and exert pressure on e6 following
up we have rook 83 Knight be one piece
that is now heading for f3 which would
for the King and pawn rook a1 a little
bit of something is lost with this move
right here attacking the knight he
already wants to go to d2 this isn't so
much of an inconvenience to black to
have the rook threatening the knight
he's pretty much wanting to go here
anyhow on his next turn a better move
would have been to exert some pressure
on the black position with rook to a5 or
rook to a6 rook a 1 it was Knight d2
Bishop e3 and we have now the minor
pieces coming off this pawn is very far
advanced and a bit cramping here to the
white side clearly this rook is now
restricted because there would be a mate
threat white gets some space here for
the King King h2 is now available and
what white is also looking to do is play
g4 so that the King can step up to g3
and eventually capture that guy
so black sees this he stops this idea of
g5 playing h5 white still plays g4 black
takes with the F pawn and after the
recapture he doesn't capture back like
this instead playing h4 this is a passed
pawn and this is upon that's stopping
the White King from even getting into a
position where he can put pressure on f3
so this is a nice
handful of moves here just a little pun
lesson I guess going on right here
recognizing what it is white needs to do
to untangle a little bit to improve his
King position this is what white is
wanting to do black recognizes this and
is having a pond here which makes the G
for break not as easily you can't get
that in so easily it still happens
capture capture but now here comes age
for if you do capture right here there
is king h2 there is King g3 and now
there's the idea of capturing on g4 and
then capturing on f3 h4 interferes with
all this this is now a past pond and
soon enough we have actually this pond
going to he's going to soon be a
connected past pond with g5 looming so
after rook d2 pressure on f2 its King
age 3 g5 this pond is going nowhere this
pond has pressure on him and what are
you going to do at this point you can't
really save the f2 pond if you play rook
to f1 at this point here
you're completely passive and black and
slowly improve their King position king
of 7 what do you do King to h2 this King
can't go too far keep in mind because
this pond has passed there's King g6 and
now what exactly King g1 trying to have
a little bit of a role reversal
defending f2 which would free up the
rook there's now rip - C - don't forget
about c4 or g4 or e5 very weakened white
pawn structure so this is completely
passive white try something active with
e4 clearing the way to observe some
pressure on the f3 pawn rook d4 white
inserts a check the King goes up here so
that when this pawn is now captured it
will happen with check ok three rook
takes c4 this is the more valuable white
pawn these
or double isolated puns so grabbing the
c-4 pond he's more important he put this
pawn here on c5 he's now passed rook
takes f7 and the idea here is to simply
march the past pawn c4 d3 I can't stop
the pawn if there's the rook exchange
rook check King d8 you don't want to
allow the white rook to get behind this
pawn King d8 interferes without King G
to the pawn continues to march okay for
one step away rope check King h3 and
what do you really do on the white side
here after King to d7 the rook is very
limited doesn't have very many choices
he could only shuffle a little bit rook
f2 and now the rook is that much more
limited in this position if he goes to
c3 there's actually this little
deflection rook takes and then black
promotes the other idea would be to play
here but now black just scoops up this
pawn here King h2 and pick your favorite
move I mean you could go here if you
wanted to you could go behind the pawn
all these pawns are ready to fall and
this is completely busted
well did it happen in the game after a
rip - f2 white tries at for the rook and
starts a check first inconveniencing the
white king after he drops back now rip
takes pawn and white basically throws in
the towel at this point white resigns if
rope takes pawn here there's so many
different wins just scooping up this
pond connected passed pawns this is just
way too much for white to deal with so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it and
feel free to leave any comments in the
comment section below
that's all for now take care bye
you
[Music]